so you were I love this I'm going to
switch to this beautiful thing to you or
fired from an early job you had as an
usher at a theater on Hollywood
Boulevard right so what happened what
how did you get fired well what happened
it was 65 cents an hour okay that I was
getting and I was an usher it was a
part-time job while I was it was a
summer and I was still a UCL UCLA
student and um we had to wear these
funny outfits like I had epaulettes and
a harem pants and a fist a hat and all
and I was standing in front of aisle's
two door this one night and back then
they would just show the movie over and
over and over so people would come in in
the middle of the movie
yeah that's what they did that it was
stupid why yeah and then it would sit
there and then they'd wait and then
they'd watch it and it would start over
again and they said oh this is where we
came in and then they leave you know so
anyway wow we were showing an Alfred
Hitchcock movie yeah now there's a
thriller and it was strangers on a train
and it was the last five minutes and it
was going to start again you know this
couple came in and wanted to be seated
in the last five minutes of an Alfred
spoiler alert I mean you know so I said
oh please no it'll ruin it for you
whether go get popcorn go to the
bathroom but you know it'll start all
over and you should see it from the
beginning well the manager came up and
said what's going on here and this woman
said she won't let us sit down and I
said but uh Mr Batten that was his name
Mr Batten
please he said Burnett I said yes he
went
it literally he went and he ripped off
my impellence
and I was fired on the spot oh my god
well
nice nice ending to this story uh
several years later when they said where
do you want your star on Hollywood
Boulevard oh my God if that's not just
you got him in the end
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going
thank you
[Music]